et les états unis qui hausse le temps
justement face à israël sur cette
question de la colonisation en prend la
direction de washington on y retrouve
notre correspondant thomas bonnet
bonsoir et thomas washington qui
s'opposent clairement aux projets de
logements d'israël dans les colonies et
c'est en quelque sorte une rupture avec
l'ère trump
oui c'est un changement d'attitude de la
part de washington qui tranche
évidemment avec les positions qui
étaient prises à l'époque par donald
trump et c'est une des premières fois
parce que jusqu'à présent joe biden
s'était plutôt montré prudent sur le
dossier israélo-palestinien mais ce
mardi donc le porte-parole de la
diplomatie américaine à employé un ton
ferme à l'égard d'israël je propose de
l'écouter
et xin wang
nous sommes préoccupés par la
publication dimanche des appels d'offres
pour 1300 logements dans un certain
nombre de colonies en cisjordanie
nous nous opposons fermement à
l'extension des colonies qui est
totalement contraire aux efforts pour
faire baisser les tensions et garantir
le calme et qui nuit aux perspectives de
solution à deux états 1
oui nous estimons aussi que tout effort
visant à légaliser rétroactivement des
colonies illégales et inacceptable nous
continuons à faire part de notre point
de vue sur cette question directement au
haut fonctionnaire israélien et lors de
nos discussions
alors cette prise de position de
l'administration de joe biden semble en
réalité s'inscrire dans la stratégie qui
était à l'époque celle de barack obama
mais évidemment cela tranche avec les
décisions qui ont été prises par donald
trump puisqu'il faut rappeler qu'en 2019
mike pompéo qui était le secrétaire
d'état américain sous la présidence de
donald trump avait déclaré que les états
unis ne considérait plus comme illégales
les colonies israéliennes en cisjordanie
et puis en 2020 il s'était même rendu
sur place pour une visite qui
s'inscrivent elles encore dans la
politique dans la stratégie de donald
trump relativement pro-israélienne il
faut aussi rappeler par exemple le
déplacement de l'ambassade américaine
dans la ville jérusalem qui avait
provoqué on s'en rappelle beaucoup de
remous dans la région d'ailleurs sur ce
point précisément il faut noter qu'il
n'y a pas de remise en question de
retour en arrière prévues par
l'administration de joe biden il faut
aussi rappeler qu'il ya deux semaines le
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères était en déplacement à
washington pour poursuivre la mise en
application des accords d'abraham ce
sont des accords qui ont été signés sous
la présidence de donald trump et qui
continuent à être mises en place par
l'administration de joe biden il ya donc
elle des limites à ce durcissement de
ton de la part de l'administration de
joe biden envers israël d'ailleurs il
faut noter que lors du discours donné de
price qui est donc lieu hier malgré le
ton ferme qu'il a employés il est resté
très évasif sur les possibles actions
que pourrait entreprendre la diplomatie
américaine contre israël sur le dossier
des colonies merci et aux abonnés en
direct de washington